في هذه الظروف نحن في هذه
الظروف نرى ان
المسؤوليه تقع على الدول المستقله والحره
لكي لا تالو جهدا للدفاع عن الشعب
الفلسطيني في الاجتماع الدولي
بطهران بعثات السياسيه والبرلمانيه
والفكريه
والاعلاميه من 59 دوله يحضرون هنا في هذه
الندوه و في هذا الاجتماع ونشكر جميع
الدول التي شاركت في هذا الاجتماع
ويسرني ان اذكر اسماء هذه الدول
بسرعه السلطات الحكوميه والرسميه والضيوف
غير الحكوميين من دول العراق ونيجر
وسوريا ونيكاراغوا
وباكستان وافغانستان
وبوليفيا
ولبنان وسلطنه عمان وموريتانيا
وتركيا رو وروسيا كوبا وكوبا والصين
واندونيسيا والامارات المتحده العربيه
وتركمنستان وطاجيكستان وايرلندا
والبوس والهرسك وتونس وماليزيا
وتركيا وافريقيا الجنوبيه وموزامبيق
وتايلاند وسر
لانكا ورومانيا واسبانيا وماليا واستراليا
وفرنسا والكويت والسويد والاردن وصربيا
وجورجيا والساحل العج والكونغو البراز
وتايلاند
واندونيسيا امريكا
افغانستان بريطانيا طاليا قان
زيمبابوي اليونان وفنزويلا
وكذلك نشكر حضور
سفراء ورؤساء البعثات السياسيه
والدوليه المقيمين في طهران وفي
الختام نقدم احترامنا ونترحم على جميع
شهداء غزه توظفه الغربيه في
فلسطين
مع ذكر الصلاه على
محمد وال محمد
وقراءه سوره الحمد على ارواح هؤلاء
الشهداء جميعا في الختام اشكركم شكرا
جزيلا على حضوركم في هذا الاجتماع الذي
يقد في طهران